his eyes are watering too boy he's stun Buck
comes out of the Zone zuk gell he's able to
Spring Dakota mermis has Hartman with him and
he takes the shot on goal it's hung on to by
Peter moric Blackhawks are averaging just a
fraction over two goals per game that's tied
last of the National Hockey League with the San
Jose Sharks mentioned they've been shut out four
times in their last six games have Chicago PR
three by tylon Johnson pan he's able to skate
with it plays for Rossy and then one- handed
around by Felino Marcus Felino with a drive to
the net and big contact no goal he put it
in but he ran into the goal tender it's a
penalty for goalie interference and moric is
down Conor Bard was wearing it Wrigley Field
with the announcement of the Winter Classic
game next year had a girl and by the way you
talk about playing hurt she's on she's injured
and she's still battling through it one lifted
in by G fav being an LA Kings draft pick he
came over with a first round pick for Kevin
Fen R off the back boards and the backand from
Sanford hit the post John Merill and that one
deflected deep Asic thought about coming out he
stays put V ler got to that puck first sets up
a shot off a couple of post it out ja blue geni
found iron twice on the same shot over for Merill
and it leaks through and now a wraparound try
moric scrambles back oh there's the horn that
puck must have gone in no wasting any more time
they definitively saw this Puck go in the net
after the shot and it goes post middle of the net
and out so post hit the camera and came right back
out it is a goal for Minnesota they'll take a one-
nothing lead here a perfect shot to the blocker it
just catch C is the inside of the post and it's in
the net and uh so the clock will go back therefore
we have a goal yeah the clock will go back to
the time in which the goal crossed the puck
crossed the goal line two nothing in Vancouver
a tough one in Edmonton a tight one in Calgary
one nothing Seattle won six to2 in that game this
was the middle game which is on TNT here's capriso
down the lane for ericon denied by morazzi we got
the finest crew they'll F that to heartbeat this
pass fired ahead just slowed up by off zuk gell
locked up with Phils Puck came to the right point
out of the box as that shot from ban goes wide is
it whistle and gigowski teas one up a tip down in
front a little contact there with moric the poor
guy had put on the brakes come back I just said
for sure it's your thousandth right we just wanted
to make sure and he was very excited to say both
of them they're fou very cool this one knocked
down to the side of the pumped it to the wrong
team there and a chance for du as he sends it over
bini couldn't get it on the other end this one
bounc to the front and du Deni by the glove Hanah
moric 12 seconds to go in the period good job
they hem in the Hawks a long shift for the Five
Guys on great stick by Kinski right on the tape
to Luchini but obviously no chance for his second
goal of the game and a good save by morazzi who is
strong line causing problems again for Chicago
as the ter out shot to the net juggled reaching
for it as morazzi can't get it covered's
backand through the open crease Marl for
Luchini cross ice adjusting mermis back hand
off the post by the linesman and here's the
first play right here by Dakota mermis going to
the backand Slick play right there Clank right
off the bar and out and there's another look at
it in the not a whole lot of room there to beat
moraz car in his first game back after missing
15 here's capriso drop pass Harman steps and
shoots off the club of moric and it leaked wide
up beautifully and there's COV always dangerous
drops it off to Harman he likes to go on High
glove and it goes right off the cheater of the
glove every single day you know it's one thing
to have a winning mindset when you're winning
it's another thing guys oh hang on here couple
of Saves by Guston in their game and we have
certainly seen that he said you know we might
not always score the goals but we're going to
get some chances and they're starting to
get them here halfway right behind the N
by blassic again now it's Jones drink wide
off the boards collected by radish radish
pass Kev rolling cck pops it over the score
Nick folino and the Blackhawks have tied the
game just a bouncing Puck that stayed with
fev and he poked it over to feno at just the
right time dzone after the fourth line kept
that puck in from Minnesota good pass there
although went off the stick first radish
keeps it on side and look at this play by
Kev KV looked like he was going to pass
it originally it goes through the legs of
B goian and quick Hands by kurv was able to
get it to the back hand right over to poino
our AT&T net cam there and a little swat at it
by the left-handed Nick poino banging that one
home pulled out of the initially by merrow but
it rolled off his stick and here's a chance for
kachuk on a breaka away Boris kachuk the head back
what a save but a left leg of Philip gson as well
to keep the game close and here kachuk trying to
get to the middle of the he loves going forehand
backand like that he likes to get the goalie to
bite a little bit more on the forehand he does
a good job of keeping it to the backand there
but it maybe he holds on a little bit oh what
a safe was bald guy taking care of a ball guy
the sck knocked out of his hand like the free
saw wanted to call won't get it here's Pia to the
Nick kicked out morz rebound morz got it to loose
Puck comes to the wall battle like crazy like he's
done all year long right there but you see blasing
get that stick whack from under capris off then
goes to the front of the net Erics neck looking
and from the top of the circles right there but
goes in with a good shot moraz look at the way
comes out of the net right there he pushes out
very aggressive and kind of slides a little bit
more and kabisov gets the rebound fav holds it
in the Chicago Zone Hartman off balance through
a pass to the slot picking it up here as ler to
the front they score Marcus Felino answers his
brother and puts the wild back on top well now
one of us had to get in a fight and one of us
had to score as well well he's got a two assists
in the game Harman battles to Nordy in the corner
keeps his balance plays it the outside it looked
like Reichel was going to be able to get that puck
out he wasn't a little two onone and a stronger
stick against him right there great here he had
one hand on his stick he was able to Corral it but
not able to get two hands on ler snaps it from him
and look at Felino goes the far post right there
and this pass is a perfect one right there by leri
I mean right over the Stick of Phillips perfectly
executed and the Stick of Marcus Felino on look
at this neutral zone positioning of Minnesota a
little one two2 not much room Rossy as Johanson
got it there baric made the save and he's able
to put the glove down on top before it could be
poked in Marco Rossi made the pass Johansson had
the first chance and then Rossy little Jam right
as Mor and Minnesota knows that that next goal all
important here Puck rolls down given away here's
denado gson went chasing in and it's blocked in
the the Tre tonight for Minnesota he sure has
here's the play by Json oh all put to the wrong
area but he did battle there with the one stick
poke check right there but there's L and mermis
playing Goen right in the crease look at look
at 10 look at look at oh it went off his heel
of escap a sure goal by Blackwell nullified oh
boy I'm not sure what what old Gus was thinking
110 left Jones straight away right side KF down
to the go line Johnson in front tapped by Nick
Felino and stopped by guson he's going to be
right there on the doorstep and there he is
there's Nick Felino there he's trying to get
a stick on it and this one goes underneath the
paddle of the Stick of gusterson but he's got
that right pad sealed nicely blassic 5 Seconds To
Go tipped in by Nick Felino and the Blackhawks run
out of time and the wild pick up a 2-1 Victory
behind the game-winning goal from Marcus Felino